[Music]
are you excited to make new friends and
share a little space romance and Mass
Effect Andromeda next month well that's
not what this video is about but Bioware
has revealed a bunch of new weapons and
skills that you'll get to use in its
upcoming RPG I'm Matt this is a game
spot news update and make sure to LIKE
and subscribe for more spacefaring
coverage of Mass Effect Andromeda
Andromeda's going to let players move
around more fluidly than previous games
thanks to the addition of a Jump Jet
that grants the ability to leap dodge
and hover in midair as for firepower
well there are four different types of
guns this time pistols shotguns and
sniper and assault rifles these fall
into three different technology types
based on where in the University come
from for example Milky Way guns use
physical ammo such as bullets while
remnant and Helios weapons utilize beams
and plasma respectively and on top of
all that players can unlock skills that
help them out in battle in various ways
such as becoming more effective with
guns deploying turrets and throwing
their enemies around with biotic powers
and of course those are just the basics
Mass Effect Andromeda releases for ps4
xbox one and pc on March 21st if you
just can't wait head on over to gamespot
check out the full gameplay video that
goes way more in-depth on the game's
weapons and skills and for more mass
effect coverage check out our video on
the five things bar where could do to
make Andromeda's multiplayer a great
experience
you